entouré d'autres réfugiés cette femme
s'effondre en larmes elle vient
d'apprendre le meurtre de sa mère dont
elle était sans nouvelles cette scène de
détresse est loin d'être isolé parmi les
milliers d'éthiopiens qui ont quitté
leur région d'origine le tigre et tous
ont fui pour échapper à l'horreur des
combats entre l'armée fédérale et les
forces locales désormais réunies dans ce
camp de fortune soudanais proche de la
frontière
ils redoutent le sort réservé à leurs
proches restés chez eux des gens sont
tués par balle avec des couteaux des
épées nous nous sommes enfuis à travers
le désert puis jusqu'aux montagnes pour
nous cacher et aujourd'hui nous sommes
venus ici
nous venons juste d'arriver nous avons
payé un prix plus élevé que quoi que ce
soit pour venir ici
les réfugiés éthiopiens serait désormais
près de 36000 selon les autorités
soudanaises
face à la dégradation de la situation
l'onu redoute une crise humanitaire à
grande échelle
près de 4000 personnes franchir et
chaque jour la frontière entre les deux
pays
les routes menant à la région du tigré
reste bloqué et nos partenaires
avertissent que les provisions seront
bientôt épuisés exposant ainsi des
millions de personnes au risque
d'insécurité alimentaire et aux maladies
depuis le 4 novembre l'armée éthiopienne
a lancé une offensive d'ampleur dans
cette région du nord de l'ethiopie ou le
front de libération du peuple du tigré
défi le gouvernement depuis plusieurs
mois les forces gouvernementales
assurent être entrés dans la dernière
phase de leur opération qui pouvait
selon elle s'achevait dans moins de deux
semaines
mais la version diffère du côté des
rebelles du tigre et qui revendique
également avoir remporté de nombreuses
batailles la réalité de la situation sur
le terrain reste difficile à évaluer
les communications en temps parties
étaient coupées dans la région et des
restrictions de déplacement sont
imposées aux journalistes le conflit
touche également l'erythrée voisins dont
la capitale a été la cible de roquettes
le secrétaire d'état américain mike
pompéo a dénoncé une tentative des
autorités tigré
de déstabiliser la région les combats
auraient déjà fait plusieurs centaines
de morts